So of course I had a
few years of non-compete after selling fitx,
which is also justified, and to be
honest, Philipp, well, I
'm a fitness guy, so I can't get out of
the number anymore and I've
actually noticed that in the last two or three
years  I can't just
play the incubator myself I ca
n't stand up
and say I support the others
I have too much energy for that
I still have too much adrenaline in my
body and I really want to give
another one in the fitness industry like yes
come on
I can't tell much but I
'll be back Fairytale hour in the OMR
podcast that's really too good to be
true but it's really a true
story about Jakob fati who came
to Essen many years ago as a refugee from Iran
and who slowly
worked his way up  at
fitness studios he was the right hand
of Rainer Schöller at McFit which later
founded its own fitness chain,
namely fitx, which sells for a lot of money,
also built up and
founded the bike brand YT  thinks he'll
bring Germany forward the Ruhr area
listen to an amazing story with Jakob fati first of all a
warm welcome jacobati hello thanks thanks
hello well I said
we're actually with the Essener well
I was born in Essen but you're
now in Essen, so to speak
you are similar is not
please eaten no no actually
a 23 I came to Essen 98
as a political refugee I think
almost everyone who knows me or who
has heard the story knows that umm
exactly and even if after that
I actually stayed totally loyal to Essen and I am  also
glad that it is so the story
you have just shortened it a lot
you can listen to the old episode
but we still have to
buy it a few minutes
so you come from Iran because you are there
with the regime at that time  you didn't
agree ne um actually
i never agreed with the regime
but actually was also
entrepreneurial i think a
bit of DNA that led to it namely
i have a Croatia was a
young age with my parents
two and a half years in what was then Yugoslavia
87 so  87 to 90 yes learned Croatian
later I worked as an interpreter
in Essen in Iran for the
Croatian-Serbian language and there were
many
economic and political
connections between Iran and um Croatia Serbia at the time and there was no one who
could speak Croatian there was that was very
rare  and at some point an engineer who I was
supervising at the time was
often in Iran because learning had installed a
light concrete factory
in Iran asked me
if I had read the book satanic heels
you know the book very
controversially I have the book I
said of course  not there
then brought the book in Croatian I
read it told my fellow students a
bit at the university that I
have the book then it was in the room why not
translate the book maybe
sell it that's why I did it and
that would be my happiest accident
life but you really have to
flee because someone can take me
home and then my mum said Jakob
what have you done so people were
looking for you who weren’t police officers now
and at the time my father was
totally so actually told me I
’ve been in all your life situations
I could help them but
you have to help yourself then
I spent three months in the Caspian more
in the house and from a friend of my
father's is first hidden then where the
Turkey border to Istanbul 2 months there
with actual documents
Croatian passport and
documents flew to Paris and
with a few from Paris by TGV to
Essen November 98 and it's so
we have to do a bit of
slow motion again so um but your
parents and you don't expect regime
opponents in that sense but you have
just saw the pharmacy this
book so it's from by Rusty uh what
he also went around the world uh
to translate Latin verses and
that was an economic
decision on your part but that meant
you had to flee, so to speak,
that's actually how it is  Of course
I didn't share any empathy with the regime at the time either,
but it was just there was
no now political
opposition or anything
to do against the regime, but simply to translate the book
I made really good money, so
I just
translated the whole thing into Persian  150
pages the book was thicker I wrote a little bit of
poetry to
make it more interesting and then I just sold it at the university and
how
many so how many how big so no no no not that
many but
I could always introduce you after
three weeks  I could afford a copy uh
copier and back then buying a copier was
not so easy and
then I could do it myself at home all the time
okay
so if you know that students thing
then or something no no no
no that wasn’t but it
was enough and  then to
completely change my life so far, uh, I say I
always tell you about it, the
happiest accident of my life, because it
brought me to Germany, first of all it was a crash, but
I found my paradise in Germany, so when my father
was totally, I sometimes say mine
Father was more German than any German,
really, really virtues like that,
reliability, punctuality, he was
a shitty regime, uh, policeman, and I was
brought up that way, and in
our culture you know there are
certain people who aren’t as well
represented as in Germany, and I’m
coming to Germany  and that's all the
way I actually
had to be for me anyway and that was
probably also a point where I
was also integrated pretty quickly we have to
come back to Iran since then, no, never again,
but his parents were
able to visit each other and stuff  my parents
came to Germany every year, my
father and my mother went
to the language school for three months every summer,
I sent Berlitz to Essen when they
came to Germany.
In the end, they were able to
speak German really well, both of them are unfortunately
deceased and  yes, but they stayed in Iran,
you have to keep that in mind until you
reach a refugee home, right,
first of all, north, that's pretty
hard Terran, so I
know the area myself, that's not
particularly warm and welcome,
but  you have to bite through first
somehow no okay, i um, my
brother had him essen lived before
me and of course i just had a little
bit of initial help i
came to unna in a home
for asylum seekers and then after two months i was
transferred to essen and i am too
recognized very quickly so that
I could then have my own apartment
then attend the language school
I went to two language schools and
then the work started it
started now let’s
slowly increase the excitement now to a
company empire with many well-known
companies too  one of the
biggest employers in Essen in the digital
space for sure or also in general
in digital space in Germany
probably already uh
started with you then with your
working hours that you worked as a trainer at McFit so
in the school chain
no exactly so in 2000
I got myself  I
applied to the deceased Rainer Schaller in Bochum,
who felt the job interviews himself at the time.
That was first in the first
studio in the Ruhr area and I was then
accepted, then I worked as a trainer
in Oberhausen in turbinhalle, so to speak,
then from trainer to
studio manager in Essen on Gladbecker
Straße, then as division manager  Calm down
then Sales Manager Germany and
then Rainer’s right hand
until
2004 and 2004 I
started my own business, first with
real estate, then I
did project development for McFit,
so to speak, but more independently as a
self-employed person with his partner from
Essen
and in 2006 I started YT or  sponsory
founded with my partner Markus
Flossmann and
founded in 2009 for X
is the bike brand ne correctly which has
grown quite big as a result,
had
last made 90 million euros in sales
before we sold to Adrien so
a relatively big pirma
that was um  but then so that you are there
you are now far from it no
um I'm still involved I'm also in the
bayrat
but I was the majority so to speak and
now I have
and how did it come about as
someone who goes to fitness studios on a large scale
headed or
fitness organizations for which Reinhard
then did real estate
how did a bike come about
actually funny well my my
boss at the time I started as a trainer my
boss at the time was
Markus Flossmann my partner at YT and
he was um mountain bike affine he
just had  started with mountain
biking and when we got to
know each other said to me hey
we have to do something together somehow
and this we have to
do something together at some point has led
to our hobby which we both
grew together a little bit
someone said  let's come
first let's create a platform where
extreme athletes and I bring sponsors
together it was called sponsory dort.com went
well 30,000 unicus we had
a lot of snowboarders a lot of kajaka a lot of
mountain bikers then
we realized we didn't make any money
so how can I not  Had away to
make money with it and then
we said we need a product
over the phone and agents in Taiwan
we have a dirt bike actually erm
out of the box so frame
sponsory young talent
dirt bike we called it and my
partner has it  Bike wrapped around his shoulders
went to Munich to
Freeride one of the big opinion makers
in this scene and said we
are new were you testing this bike they
said yes we are
actually testing in this category right now
a right time to be the right place
and  we customers with the bike at that time
won the price-performance test as
absolute
complete new starters and that was the
origin of the YT but the bike was
n't special at all
how could the winning good components
good quality and super cheap price
due to the online um so direct you
can Huma back then we already
had an online shop and
within 10 days we sold the 150 bikes that
we had ordered at the time and
that led to people being
born, so operational
sales were then raised to 90 million
Word yes, what were
the decisive levers to get it so big,
like it is in
entrepreneurship, there were a
lot of ups and downs, so we were
very often on the edge of actually
existence and
I have to honestly say
brand brand brand  Markus a
real one actually so in his
DNA topic brand and branding and
of course the topic we have always made this
price-performance ratio
winner always
the best prices due to the direct sales
customers who also offer good prices top
quality and a very very
unusual concept  Marketing and then I had
marketing that was so extraordinary
first of all um actually totally the crème
de la crème of the mountain bike scene
we made sure of that as a testimonial at the beginning
because we
were different not because we paid so much
because we were so LG you know
dear Anke caged our our claim was
very courageous then say over the next few
years what money we made
and we with Christopher Walken the
Oscar winner a a spot device I do
n't know if you've looked at it
from our Bike Jeff See friendship
ready  defined that went around the world
we got a lot of props
even for the right
marketing goose worldwide we brought
our bike with you that you take out of the box
and every customer actually
gets two world cup
downhill wins with it, so with the
classic one  So don't trade
now tuned bikes that have been totally pimped up,
but and such measures have
led to someone becoming a
champion in gravity
Mountain Viking and you
never opened up to learn until today so
we have in San Clemente so  in
USA milk so you can't
sell bikes but you can test bikes
you can see
in gillford in UK we have a one
mill and a third is planned
now in USA in volumes and we
have a mill in Forchheim where the
central sits warm furrow
from from YT sits in Forchheim but you
were your food back then how did it happen so was
also founded in Essen in
Burgaltendorf
yes and then erm but Markus came from
Bavaria from Neustadt an der Eich and
then they said okay  because he also
ran the operative company but said
the company would be relocated to Bavaria and
um how much of the business is in
Germany today how much is
abroad um so almost 50% is in
Germany and the rest worldwide and that
would probably benefit from the bicycle boom
madness
madness so Corona was just brutal in the last few years
but we have a very, very small
market share in the USA and in the USA the
focus is on gaining market share and
the art now also lies in marketing
and sales and not so much in
sourcing, these bikes there  from
Taiwan to get that that
works relatively easily it's
a combination of all
product design so it's very
product design-heavy that's
sports equipment so we don't sell
mountain bikes where you then get
bread rolls around the corner but these are
sports equipment the normal in between  two
between three to 7000 €.  okay um well well
now we've made it up now
in the 22 then to 90 million sales
that's already a word and then
also said okay now it's so big
and it needs pretty much every
professional investor and then
you passed it on or at least you did it for the time
being  we found out from
management that technically I was no longer
able to take the company to the next
level. I
poached Amazon Prime-Chef samnicals back then,
but Europe
Dach
then
took over the management and so with now
the management is being transferred to a
third party  -manager we also
made the decision said hey
we need more capital to take the next step
we need more
tailwind and then the
decision was made it was good timing
too straight good numbers and Adrian also
applied for us we have a beauty
contest  done, of course, by being
commissioned and there were five
very, very interested parties, but
Adrian was definitely the right
partner, we’re happy about that, okay,
and while everything was going on, so
while it grew and you also
helped there operationally, you did
but then fitx was also founded, so that
the the fitness studio chain that you also
know, I think, is
not quite as big as many years,
Felix has meanwhile been 102 102 since the
first one was also in Essen, but the first one, I
think, is always right in the street  Food
okay okay and that was just
the idea along the lines of I've seen
how McFit works, I can
actually do it better, right, right, so
it wasn't really that much
different from McFit, what I did back then,
I always thought of McFit
a lot  male very much
geared towards men,
so to speak, very well-behaved and then I said my
female brand female colors courses
including a still honest price can
lead to more people
being drawn into the studios and that is what
happened  within the industry
actually took away members but
I don't think that's going to be a
new target group or
actually created the
people who never went to the gym
what's the logic so you
knew exactly if there's a McFit here
then I need somehow 5 km  Distance
can I open the next studio
or how big are the
catchment areas, so there is a
principle of 5 kilometers or 15, 15 and
20 minutes driving time and then
certain numbers have to be right, I mean the
Ruhr area, you know six
million people yourself  tight, so to speak,
terror and that was actually
good I unknowingly made the first studio also
very close to McFit
location so without me doing that and that
worked out well and then blueprint was okay for me at
first I did
expansion for fitx I stood
Today expansion made fit for me I
know where the locations worked well
and then I
also looked for Felix locations in the corners and that
worked great what do you think
what is decisive for the success in the end
i.e. the rent you
pay or  the price you
can offer at the end or whatever, as always
in the shop, a combination of
all of them, of course, the location is extremely
important. You ca
n’t change the location, so no compromises, so
they must be well located, many
lanes with very good visibility,
total parking spaces  important
of course cheap rent and otherwise it
depends on the concept how what
you present so I'm
generally a
budget thinker I can't get any
luxury products
somehow and um with Felix there was
a product that actually
offers everything before 15 €,  I started with €15,
which was the cheapest offer on
the market at the time, and that included everything,
so courses, drinks, 24 hours, very, very
modern studios and
I think that helped and
we are in Germany in
Germany discount world champions
how big  has it turned out in terms of sales
so I have two 2019
as you know that companies
then sold my number to my
investors and at that time we
made 110 million euros in sales
should there be two companies or do you have
two companies both like that  Size
100 million my more profitable what is
better bicycle trade the chick or
fitness studios
I would say fitness studio yes better
dimensions better margin because such a
fitness studio so if we
somehow run one like that now what can you
keep left over there 10% or so yes it
is
dependent  actually from from the big
from but you already have
25% of
the price that's really great and with the
bike it's less because then
procurement is more complicated it's
just a business that also
comes with a lot so it's technically complex and you
have to deal with material  you have to
deal with an engineer who sometimes
makes mistakes, so
fitness is a grateful and
it's also an even more
exciting industry that's
very young when you look at what
fitness industries have an important
history aren't  more than 30
years before that, but fitness is such a
luxury product you didn't know where to
put it, there were gyms in the past
and now it's such an accepted
industry with really blatant investments
in this market and I think there
's even a lot more to change
if you look now, so to speak, then
the two developments of these
two companies were probably central to
everything that came after, because in the
meantime we'll
talk about it you've founded a lot of
new things and you also say
you have all the money that you use it for
earned these two five
one is completely sold the
other large parts erm but
actually you could have retired after the two
company foundations and sales
the volume that
it came to you a cash is then something like
15 million and something like that
yes  a bit more so that's
already sufficient for several generations of
normal consumers actually yes
actually that
could actually be the case but I
think I said last time
so at a certain point in time
the money was no longer the focus for me
but so simple  move something and I
also have a high degree of
gratitude towards Ruhrgebiet
Germany Essen in general and
I also want to give something back and I ca
n't do much I can only do
companies that get me rolling
and with that I give something
back okay  uh okay that means on
the way it was always receding 98
uh arrived in Essen and then,
so to speak, 20 years 21 22 years
later then de facto probably one
of the richest people in Essen and
one of the even the richest people
must also say Germany
at least  I think the manager magazin
Top 1000 list goes up to 100 million
or something like that, so there you are,
that's just a
sensational development, sorry, how many of
these species there are in Germany,
unfortunately,
I think there are enough, but
maybe I have  not
knowing how lucky I am and being invited to it
but I think it's extraordinary because I
came to Germany as a 23-year-old I had to first of all there were
a lot of hurdles I have to
learn the language it's not easy
I remember  the days when I
was in the studio at McFit and had to
hold a studio management price management then have to go to the studio manager meeting and
the language didn’t work like today it was
2002 no and I had brutal
stage fright standing in front of ten people
and just selling them strategy
and  and I think that I'm
proud of that because it wasn't
always easy but now
I'm laughing about it because somehow I
managed to do it with a lot of diligence, a lot of
quantity, just somehow to make up for the lack of quality
you're kind of giving full throttle seven days a week
now  maybe not today, but
back then I was brutal, so no
days under 18 hours, so I really
really hung in but full
pot when you see you like that today, I
mean you are already a
conspicuous person now in the sense
that afterwards you still walk around like a
Sports part athlete but also with
tattoos and that's how it's always been with you,
so to speak, fan culture or subculture or
something like that, no, I have, I have,
too, that was a development for me too,
I actually got my first tattoo when I was
32, my son
I have Elias on my upper arm and then
x came from fitx and then it started, so
then we searched and I liked that
too, I never was too, so I
never really wanted to
dress up or somehow give myself a corner
where I wasn't and  I was
fine with that, too,
most of them couldn't see it, although
we're recording it here for
Youtube, always then podcasts quickly
on Youtube too, but now I'm sitting here in such
an ex-large tracksuit,
curly tattooed up to the shoulder,
it's not like that  Type where you
would think okay the story but so
very impressive and above all what
comes after now now
further so now you have
made this first development so to speak and then decided I
actually found the incubator in Essen right right
that was mine so I always
always  said ey if it's cool to branch out into a fitness studio
it's also cool to do real estate in the bicycle brand
but I said hey the greatest
effect would be if you got other people
to do something
and also support them and so just
maybe the first experiences first  Giving cash injection
and um someone 20 12 where I was
in the highest expansion phase came up with
the name queerleis what if you
talk to people and say hey
an idea and if ten people are in the room
say I had this idea too
so but entrepreneurship is always
mine  In my opinion, between having an idea
and implementing it takes so much so much
time and then I said between
creation and realization you can
tell and then the name came up and I
always had this dream
I said ey that's perfect for me that packs
a punch  I put a drawer and
at some point in Essen, where my
adopted home is,
I start to help the others
to do something and um, that
actually happened in 20 15 with David
Ewald and my partner and yes,
in the meantime we have actually founded almost 35 ventures
ourselves or
involved in it and there
are now 22 of them and they
all have very good hopes that what
we are all going into now 22
what Amazon
first opened always in Essen the
origin and now right now very
close to you will open one in Hamburg exactly
Stresemannstraße
you told me that is then
basically you can then what is
a sauna that is a that is a
nest with the sauna with the whirlpool
and
relaxation area and you can rent this nest for up to
four people for several hours
and with  a lot of
privacy actually it would be
okay
to rent the wellness area but just in a small
team or alone and then
we say not
having to be in the sauna in large numbers now
but to have your own peace
and  actually number 9 to
think about these possibilities and
you call that wellness okay that’s also a
bit of real estate play because you need
the right space for it no
absolutely I know my way around also
starts fitx so let’s be real estate
now let’s expand and we have
very very exciting
trunk there um found he was an
architect for me at fitx then I
asked him at some point you don't
feel like doing something together with me
then what he said yes then wellness
developed and where did
the idea come from um we just have
the idea just made better from
my point of view and as far as the brand is concerned, in terms of
quality and so we
actually had a profit right after the foundation in the
first store and
who else finances it so does
everything ourselves but I mean when we have
real estate there  have to rebuild and
everything that is within 40 i.e. within
queerleiste I
financed the snack myself but even if
the concept is a bit fun you can
also finance it yourself it’s
several locations and so or no no
so that’s my cable too a
whole  It quickly became apparent that the
banks also like the model and
of course we get
financing, but as always,
you also need equity capital, you need
certain commitments, you need guarantees
or something
ten percent and then we
brought in some cash,
but the model can actually be financed by
cash flow and banks over the next few years, I would say,
how much wellness do you think there
will be in Germany one day,
so I would say
Germany can tolerate
150  up to 200 nights locations with so
I would say someone will
have 4000 nestar in Germany,
that means branches each with 20 nests
if you have 200 you have the space or something
and then in the final stage of expansion that will
probably make around
far more  much more yes okay I would
say quadruple okay but that is
now yes then if it has been two
hours or you can see
now it is supposed to be
rolled out that is there at least in
two cities now it has to be
cleared out further that’s how it is  we are
now starting in Cologne Bonn then in Hamburg
and then the journey continues
and that means you already have
new things then tell me
the next mistake exactly the next
thing I told you at the time I think I
also told you about kicks in basketball
retailers  So basketball
authenticator it says in the language of the
Nike and Jordan of the world I
took it over from Zalando so I don't have to
make that clear Zalando bought that a
kicks this year also a retail store there
is a retail chain kicks so I
think you know such a sport
interested circles and  umm
you bought that from Zalando in the end exactly so
Zalando took over the company with the
aim of actually integrating the company within the
Zalando world
umm they did
n’t really manage that and
made big losses due to their large size and then they were
actually entitled to it
Then
I came and negotiated with uh Boris
Evanstein
from
Zalando and uh yes yes
small world is okay and then there are
eleven new locations we are opening this
weekend in Berlin on Kudamm you are
cordially invited a flagship  Store
that is looking for its equal so it will be
really really cool and but 70 percent
of the business is online okay and
why do you buy something like that
after all the building experience to
have a really structuring experience or did you see something right away
or how did it come about  Well, I have to be
honest, I'm a
sneaker head myself, you know, no, sneaker
fan and uh, uh, basketball fan too, and
at the time the
decision was actually quite
opportunistic at first, I
said hey the company had a history
and 30 years old they were one of the
first ones who also started online in
93 the company was founded in Munich
and um I spoke to a Nike um in
Amsterdam and a Nike um
actually top manager
um like I said we see Biscuit as the
number one basketball authenticator in
Europe but something has to be done
otherwise this status is
lost in the form of investments
in technology investments in good
managers for the company and then
also retail and then I also
consulted a bit
with the people who have experience
with Boris levels stone with people who are
also in the online area and  then
they said to me yes if you invest in 10
million euros wide to 10 million
more in that in the company
then there will be shoes out there
and I decided that very intuitively at the time and
said
hey let's do it we'll do it  we've
managed to do it and it's been
going well so far today, um, we
made 40 million euros last year,
we actually managed the company again in
a
plus zone, so not me
personally, but two of our very, very good
managers, Marc Petzerath and
Dennis Rohrmann, come from this world
one from Nike others from Snipes and they
are doing great work and that is also
one of the
most promising babies of ours but
that is 100% up to you now okay and
someone to be involved in it and that
soon but that is
also conceivable and planned  because
we actually want to expand to the next level with
biscuits
within Europe Barcelona is the
next step then Paris London and
possibly also Dubai and
there we are actually looking for
capital so
sorry for shops like that I think
I got it from Sven food  learned
someone from Snipes the founder that's
part of it Deichmann that's
crucial founder here also a
sneaker chain can sell successfully
someone who heard the podcast a
few years ago anyway what's
crucial is that you get the goods
I think opening the shop
is one thing  or a chain like that, but you
need the goods from Nike, from Adidas, from the
big brands, and if that
works for you then you have a chance,
absolutely, and that was also a
decisive statement from Nike at the time,
so they have already placed kicks with
themselves  Sport Authenticator Nike is
actually dealing with the topic of allocations very radically,
which means that in the next few years they want to
see brand themselves as the way to delete
dealers actually exactly but not clicks
so biscuit still gets very good
allocations and will also assert themselves in the future
I even better because we are
also doing our homework, so in the
sense of Nike presenting the true ones here,
presenting
digital, so to speak, digital development,
then also to deal with three
what we did with metal, we
have with
young formats with rooftop from Dortmund
and a couple of very experienced founders when the
collective was founded where we also then
go into the topic of the web area now with
the collective so kicks meta-collective
and that is they always have to introduce
digital fashion but also with a
physical
utility extension in life that
means you we  drop soon nfts that
you buy as a
community member and so
you have better access without a in
releases in clothes that we
bring out and and my colleague the
florinke who lives in West Germany uh
and for us were somehow in the editorial departments
otherwise uh researcher is under
other thing he has now written down for me
you have also tried a concept where he
says where I should ask you or man
that at least didn’t work right away
and you wanted to
make a new attempt at fitness studios
so the John June brand
actually opened in Düsseldorf
The timing wasn't so good, so we
opened in the middle of the most severe phase for
Coronas, so we could
n't actually invite any customers in. I
still think that the
world needs this concept, that was a concept
aimed at
a little more prevention and also more
actual
with a very
sophisticated circle with such a with
its cognitive cognitive training
program and
best location in Düsseldorf at the harbor
opened
top location two very very good founders
timing was not good and we
actually had to take this concept
out again tell me because now
we’ll come to a few  Hits but it
has to be a bit balanced and
not everyone who thinks okay that ca
n't be the only hits nobody has
so that means that didn't
work or did you
reinstate it understandably
with Krone
but now you have too  Speaking of the
companies 35 founded in the end
22 got through so logically 13
pieces that were primarily
e-commerce companies or what kind of companies
that didn’t manage a lot of
e-commerce business ass which we
also deliberately spread a lot
many  different areas so I
'm coming now models that you
just knew before certain products
we have one a company Pilk the
plant milk so to speak but in
a very ecological way you must
have and you have a mixer and
you can with the pattern 67  liters of milk
make that's what we founded and when
we realized that it wasn't
working, we just had to take the pressure off
and accordingly we also had a good founder with us for another
eight brands that we got rolling,
but then
we realized that you  i.e. that
you can’t bring the company so that this model
to a large scale and
then we also processed the things
back again, keeping the brands
and also believe that one
or the other might work at a different
point in time, but we
decided not to continue
but do the basic concept of the incubator that
you continue to believe in. It
already existed with Rocket Internet or earlier
with Team Europe or there are
also various other examples of
incubators that
have always existed in recent years, but
I am very familiar with them  few that
still exist, so most incubators
stopped at some point, but you say
no, the concept will continue to work, I
believe in it, yes, I believe in it, we've
learned a lot, so we've also so
I've really learned a lot,
like we're doing now  tackle the matter
which type of founder we choose which
mod how we also verify a model a
business model and so
simply check it for plausibility that has
become different so me so we have
everything that karma comes with this
corner at the beginning let's just scatter it
and do a lot  was also good because
we also learned a lot, but
today I think with the experience
we have had in recent years
we would not do it again, but
we would still push company
building and incubation,
we
actually do that  I founded a few more
campaigns exactly
my bill, which I also
told you Fitness App that sold like a uh
Creator I
have thoughts in my mind but that means
we did it, we
gave it my bill and we
got shares of them
exactly
then we have trim trim is a fitness
accessory brand that we actually
started very well, but the timing
wasn't so good either, so after Corona, where
actually, uh,
during Corona, everyone
bought retail discs and boilers from home, but the brand has a
lot of power  and I heard you
also have a fitness studio down here in the
basement, yes, I definitely have to have a look, but
yes, yes,
I have to send a few things there,
somehow, in any case, um, we
invested quite a bit
in a
large carpentry workshop in the middle of Essen West
take mudia
bought item no completely newly
founded so the property of our
new campus which we would move in at the beginning of June
I would say we
opened a large carpentry why
does someone make the digital film power that
builds big brands why does he open a
carpentry also has history
always dealing with people I knew the
founder or the carpentry shop that
always supplied me with furniture for fitx
and I also got to know other concepts
and at some point
I asked him if that was his
shop, he said no, he is the
manager and then  we
said hey we can't do something together
or buy from your owners the
er while carpentry
because we don't need so much
craft was interesting for
me
and yes we negotiated with his
bosses so to speak they
said they sell  not the store and he
said okay let's
build something new together then
we went about it differently
we gave a cool name a cool brand
and yes we are now working at full
capacity huge automated
carpentry directly in Steinburg from
essen-zentrum
in  so not much in shape yet
but it is planned how to get to 20
million euros a year so
with one location or something
again with one okay yeah
wow that’s the carpentry so if
I tell you carpentry you have to see us
visit that's very important
that's already a large
automated
I would say series production and
should then also be made at other locations
or the old one
with my soft spot, so to speak,
for also generally our
entire cosmos is always with physical
things  life shopfitting, we
actually discovered a weakness for handicrafts
for ourselves and then
at some point we also founded a GU Maker,
so it was mostly a very small
boutique GU general contractor who
also takes on very exclusive conversions for
ourselves and we have a
brand under it  came into being in Hamburg and
so we now want to build on large styles of
craft centers, the first we
have just built the cast now, we demolished the old tennis hall we bought,
it is currently under construction and you
always have to introduce it, so we make
craft boxes, that means in
such a large area  comes in a plumber,
an electrician, a tiler, everything that has
to do in Tannenburg,
maybe a carpentry shop, and we
provide the administrative
tasks
of craftsmen, we take the
agreement rework for craftsmen
a bit precisely, but
of course, craftsmen need a
fixed seat in the warehouse they have  Of course
it's not coburking space in
that sense now,
but a craft center
in Hamburg there is a model the
city of Hamburg made Meister Meile it
says it's similar but not
what we want to do and um I have
so I'm
100% sure  that the world needs something like that, so
Germany
in particular is very
fragmented in terms of craftsmanship, incredibly
disorganized, there are an awful lot
but they are not organized among themselves
and we believe that we
can also give crafts a completely different image and you came up with that
through your experience with the
Carpentry exactly you saw okay
that could also be done that way or was
there any role model for or something like that no
we did we actually
always spun around a bit
and someone kept
condensing the concept more and more
then came the property then I got it  I
said okay on our campus we're doing
small examples from Hamburg's
carpentry shop, so we also have a
plumber, then a metal worker comes along
and that's such an easy test for us,
and now in Kaarst we're doing the whole thing
officially and under
the craftsmen's center  to build
it will be an investment volume
of 20 22 million euros for his
new center yes and you do that
yourself again you have a
financial bank there again and of course um
actually financed when you
say banks then I assume again and
again  the Commerzbank because what is
happening now has somehow gone beyond
all his reasons and
entrepreneurial activities you
have now become a kind of
testimonial for the Commerzbank
so you see yourself on the
internet men somehow didn’t fall in
love that’s true I would have that
through the financing  for our campus
I got to know one of the board members of
Commerzbank, already
board member
Southwest Mario Perretsch, and
because of my Croatian language skills,
a very, very
explosive mutual love
almost came about and
then I was asked if I
was ready, that it was Monja  being there
and that wasn't easy for me from
Nationalbank Essen is my house bank
regional bank the board member is a
good friend and even a member of the advisory board and but
I accepted that anyway because he's
also totally interesting for me and yes
we don't do a lot with Commerzbank
only with Commerzbank but it
's an independent bank but it's
like that, we just saw each other here in
Hamburg, so yesterday
today is a few days in Hamburg because
you're really doing a shoot here too
and so it's like a
model-like now also
yes sometimes I wonder why do
you mix it up like that Simon yes
okay yes we have now had a new
shoot Commerzbank
have extended it with me for another year now
you just said uh I was fit
always fascinated that Felix did
then somehow June tried and
now I think you can
tell a little bit you try although
they do yes then it didn’t work out again
something new again in the
fitness area still be next to each other
exactly so I
sold through and fitx couple of course  I
had a non-competition ban for years, which
is also justified, but
Philipp, to be honest, I
am a fitness guy, so I ca
n’t get out of the act and I’ve
actually noticed in the last two or three
years that I can’t just
play the incubator, so I myself
can't stand up for myself now
and say I support the others
for that I have too much energy for that
I still have too much adrenaline in my body for that and
I really want to make a comeback in the fitness industry I'm not allowed to reveal much but
I'll be back  I am of the opinion that there
is still a lot to change in this industrial sector worldwide I have a
positive feeling that there are already
a lot of studios so where you look
the fitness studios yes yes yes
you had the feeling back then that I
founded fitx and everyone advised me against it
said what another
gym that was actually good
me bad that I
did that and um I think that's
my thesis the fitness industry is
still very very young and fitness is an
industry has no star in its
sky so there is no Apple in the
fitness industry  worldwide there is no
Mercedes there is no
Amazon and I think that needs to be
changed and um I want to
try that again with all the
global stuff already really
okay and I mean you
already teased me a bit based on my
understanding of the  Concept and you do
n't have to go into depth, but it also played
a role that people should get to know each other, so to speak,
so it should also embody an aspect of connection and
belonging, but
the most important thing is the topic of
fitness and fitness platform again,
um, I'll be in  Eating the whole thing
starts because makes
hope next year in January okay okay
so that's a little bit more but there's
no background to it yes yes I'm
very strong in the background and um
I also believe very strongly that
this industry deserves a disruption
and then that's it  again so
that you are now looking for real estate
and looking where can we then do the
first really correctly
before and shock than very deceased
yes more shock more than a
shock so I have Rainer I have to
honestly say a large number of my
experiences to the best of my knowledge  and
what I actually noticed at the beginning was
thanks to him, who gave
me a great many
opportunities, you always have to
introduce me, I wasn't even two
years in Germany, I started as a coach
and then I had a steep
career and then that  was
also connected to him who gave me a
lot of trust
really helped a lot and wait there
must be disappointed that you have
competition for you, so to speak, you
said yes that was a reason
but we also had others who were good
but that  it was already when i
became a competitor then there was none
so there was silence between us
but i always
showed my gratitude and my respect to him even when
we argued and when this
tragedy happened so i have to
honestly say that was it  for me one of the
so after my parents died that was
the worst thing for me yes
even though he hasn’t spoken for years yes yes yes
I mean we
haven’t spoken to each other for years
but his photo or our photo is
always on my fridge  At home I
've always had him in my heart, I've
always spoken well about him and that really
hit me, it's
still inside me, I
honestly have to say
now again about the two companies, so
if you can compare them, they're
like that  I think it's similar in
terms of sales so the bicycles and and
and gyms which I've already learned from the two
films about 150
million or something a little more
you say now we're 200 somewhere
in between yes but what's that because the
more valuable company so we already have
understood the more profitable is then
probably logically the
more profitable or the more valuable yes I'll
tell you today is of course
a completely different level for you on the road
for me is the best product that is
available in Europe so as the current model
that the owners of fitx go too
so very well focused they don't get bogged down they
focus on what is
there I think
Felix also has a completely different value today but it
should last longer
yes yes I might
not be unhappy with it if if
fitx were still there  would be because of course Corona
was such a dent but you can see
the numbers are increasing again, people are
going back to fitness studios because that
’s definitely not
such a by-product anymore, it’s
now like brushing your teeth, everyone wants
and will  what to do for yourself and
gym are also not just to
provide health you don't
just train but you also go
because you're looking for social contacts because I
just had to check that what you
told me privately also with the podcast
you've already told when we now
So Felix belongs to whoever bought the group, so they, they
were my partners and
investors, who also financed a large part
for you
back then, when I just didn’t have that
many opportunities, an
investor looked for me and I then got my
shares  sold to with a group and they
are now 100% company of it for
nothing okay let's just say
a few words to conclude what's
happening in Iran in general so the
development people yes I actually have
tattooed woman life freedom on on upper arm woman  Life freedom
okay
and
yes I have a lot of regrets I have
that in Iran I have a lot of regrets in the direction
because many people live a lot too
and this revolution has cost me a lot of suffering.
I hope with all my
heart that something
will change at some point because I  I think
Iranian country that
has a lot of potential, a lot of
human potential, an awful lot of
well-educated people, a lot of
young people and um yes, in this
touranerei really
just a mixture of religion and greed
and greed has really cost the country its head and
neck and  it hurts so when
I was young I already said
[ __ ] it so I'm in
Germany now that's my homeland I have
mine so I know where I come from I
have my roots and I also know
my roots but now when you
get older and look back  then it
hurts so it really hurts and
I hope that it will last for a long time
so if you are probably
closer then you
probably have old friends there or
relatives there it looks like
I would have something to do there  Or is it all
just waves and in the end it does
n't matter much so if I just do it with a
lot of passion I'm not so
deep inside now that I follow it every day
but on my own I have to
honestly say that it was a wave but
a big wave  there were waves but
they were very, very small and I think
that is the beginning of something the beginning of
a change when that will happen
no one can say how that will happen but I
think something will change but we are
talking about beginning March 23 so the
wave was yes  like last fall
I think it was relatively big so
22 there is a feeling again, at least in the
German media landscape, it
has become a little less on the ground has also
become less on the ground evaporated yes
evaporated but it’s also like that
the
local government is also dealing with something like that
brutally  a very, very strong intel,
i.e. the secret service, which then also
takes care of the opposition and I believe, but
we know that this is a
violent dictatorship, so nothing will
last forever, it cannot be, that
something will also change in Iran at some point,
if I am sure
otherwise a few words to eat
maybe because I know we are
both eating at heart now or that’s
why we’re so cool you’re also doing
quite a lot of
real estate projects meanwhile so everyone who is
saying okay now it’s going to be a
bit very special we can
also switch off from time to time  but you have
now
taken over a couple of really special properties no, that’s right so FC real
state so FC real also such a
football-oriented name for his real
estate company we wanted to
do something different so real estate
FC real but we don’t have a letter
from Real Madrid  got
founded 20 18 and uh actually one of
the most prominent purchases of
ours was
last year the year before last
cardinal hengbach out in will be
a very very the most beautiful part of town
maybe is one of the
most beautiful in the south and because such a large
property that then from the city  you
can buy from a diocese you are from the
diocese of Essen that was a
seminary where priests were
trained now
the training has become smaller
and the property was no longer
needed and the church simply put it up for
auction there were 60
applicants but they  Not only could we score with the highest
price points, but there had to be
a combination of price and concept
that you do there and
our partner case and there Hans Reidig
and a top architect from Essen also
came up with the best concept and we
actually ended up with the property among these 60 applicants
actually there are a number of
interested parties where we
can do development I hope
that is a school campus will instead
have signaled instead needs
seven schools in the next few years,
including grammar schools and I think
cardinal hengstbach grammar school would be a
really good fit if  you
could build a grammar school there
the talks are going on right now the
talks are going on right now bought
yes yes that was bought a long
time ago now we just did it for a short time now
we have almost 250 Ukrainian refugees
inside so that was actually a coincidence
the city
approached us because back then it started and
the refugees wanted hotels in Essen
and they had to move out of the hotel and that
was a suitable property that he
could handle very quickly and very well
just
continue
the property
cost almost 20 million euros that
's 44,000 square meters of property with
an amazing history in Essen too
that actually before the war the
hir queue banking family belonged to a
jewish family who then there's Essen
is rich in tradition there's even a
subway station at hirschlandplatz  exactly and
yes and we already have a vision
for this elementary school as well, what
should happen there Cardinal Hengst guard house
so that the property on it is
hopefully high school
and otherwise you are open to business so
whoever is listening now and somehow
maybe says okay I have  an idea
I somehow need or would need
a suitcase or investor you're
always looking for people always for people for
talented founders but also
for people who just come to us
and
simply take over certain mature Avengers and take them to the next level
so we're looking for a lot of
people you're really in that said yes
happened 23 years ago and uh yes and
I gave back a little something
but I will give everything to do
my services in Essen, especially in the Ruhr area and then finally also in Germany
and I am now me  I
still call myself and continue to be a
perfect German Persian, so
to speak,
everything is clear Jakob, first of all, thank you very much
for coming around again and how did we
stay in touch again until he's
here in Hamburg at the festival
and so I'll want to meet up we can
see if we do something there so that we do
n't
organize meetings or people are interested
there is a great deal of calm until the
delegation traditionally always has a look we'll
go down first
let's do everything ciao ciao ciao